[Music]
why don't we speak next to um
you know there's just so many people
waiting today
what if we speak to ryan from austin
ryan from austin you're on the air
hey david thanks for taking my call my
pleasure i just had a quick question uh
what do you think the democrats
messaging should be going into the
upcoming midterms uh giving the current
political landscape do you think that
gun control and abortion rights are
gonna be winning issues in november or
do you think we should have a more like
broad progressive message you know 99 of
the time i would be saying abortion and
gun rights are not winning issues and it
should be primarily an economic message
we are in a unique situation where i'm
actually wondering
maybe the focus should be on the right's
determined uh inaction
on gun issues
and
its support of the overturning of roe v
wade by the supreme court which is very
unpopular with the american public and i
would almost never say this every
election i've covered i have not not
said this i said don't talk about guns
don't talk about abortion
this particular time the public seems so
repulsed with what's going on with those
two issues
what the hell maybe it is a good
strategy this november
yeah i agree um the only thing i worry
about is i wonder if that public
propulsion is going to
continue to be there in november or if
it's going to fly away it's still five
months from now and who knows what will
happen in the next five months that's my
hesitation as well but i think compared
to other elections it actually might be
a winning message this time around i
don't know and listen you know what
otherwise it's not like it was looking
that great for democrats anyway so i
don't know that i have a better idea for
them
yeah exactly what the hell may as well
run on it yeah
all right well thank you so much okay
thanks for the call uh we're going to
keep taking calls after a very short
break so please don't hang up i will get
right back to the phones uh in a moment